I went a long way with the American
office actually I didn't see Aventine
all of them but I've seen an awful lot
of them and thoroughly enjoyed it it's
different from our show but at the same
time when there are similarities I was
able to kind of see what people liked
about our show the office when I think
of the office it's hard not to think of
the experience of the office because the
experience was so genuinely funny it was
like a crash course for me in doing
something that I have enjoyed since
which is occasionally just trying not to
act at all generally like trying to do
away with any artifice or anything
between you as a performer and the
character and the audience is like just
be absolutely as real as possible don't
do any acting and that's it I mean ever
since really that's sort of been my
favorite type of acting I'm a sales rep
which means that my job is to speak to
clients on the phone about quantity and
type of paper whether we can supply it
with them and whether they can pay for
it and I'm boring myself talking about
it
so Tim allowed me to you know I've got a
brother called Tim even and I sort of
based little bits of my interpretation
of Tim little bit on myself I'll be
seeing a little bit on family members
and so yeah it was that was what I
thought of the character and he was
pretty much the conduit for the audience
you know and I think that was the first
time that I'd played that sort of
character and I've played them since
you're fired Keenan drunkard warning
Oh God what's he been saying it's all
true I'm a sucker for good writing and
the writing on the office by Ricky
Gervais since the merchant was just
she's really good it was really really
good what I loved about them was they
sort of they didn't know anything but
they knew everything German they kind of
they were very unschooled and very
untutored but had a freshness to them
that was alarming actually
when I first heard about it of course I
was quite resistant I thought why do
they need to do this I'll just show us
you know and actually once I saw the
show I really liked it I went a long way
with the American office actually I
think I didn't see Aventine all of them
but I've seen an awful lot of them and
thoroughly enjoyed it it's different
from our show but at the same time when
there are similarities I was able to
kind of see what people liked about our
show the Jim and Pam thing kind of
echoing the Tim and Dawn story I was
able to sort of see oh yeah that's why
people really love that story is just
very - very sweet normal people falling
in love in a very sweet way very
cleverly and the whole conceit of it
sort of being like a mock documentary
was that any glance like anything that
you put over to somebody else has picked
up so you don't have to overact you
don't have to over egg it like the
cameras seeing everything or everything
that the you know the team wants the
camera to see so we'd only take you know
me or Lucy Davis who played dawn just
you know to do to do that and people
people know people know what it is and I
and I loved doing that it's like a sort
of an exercise in honing subtlety
actually from from a crafts point of
view okay good that's fine yeah all
right
it's a bit dark actually I didn't bring
a flash probably what Billy Newsies
actually okay don't be disappointed
they're not in now yeah it was the thing
that people shouted at me for a good
couple of years you know from my own
personal life it was the character that
made people know who I am even before I
knew who I was and I'm still on that
journey I remember being in New York
once in a luggage shop and people would
come up and quote like date David
Brent's lines to me so David Brent had
some horrendous lines and so I'm just
looking at luggage and this guy came in
and when I think there's been a rape up
there and I thought that a not my line
be
Shh see I'm off The Hobbit I think
whether you're James Cagney or me or
whoever you know name any one of a
hundred actors whoever you are and what
whatever you're bringing it has to be
real right so if you put James Cagney in
a film now he would seem kind of big
right he would that was like that's a
strong flavor
I didn't disbelieve anything he ever
said right nothing because it he means
it right so whether you're doing
something that is up to 11 or something
that's 2 or 3 as long as you invest it
with the truth of that moment hopefully
the audience will go along with it and
believe it I can't the thing about
something like The Hobbit is because
it's a it's a big old beast right and
it's fantastical I mean literally it's a
you know it's a huge fantasy story but
unless you imbue it with real humanity
then why should people care I always
felt that Ian McKellen did it really
really well you know he like he walked
that line between the big and the sort
of epic and the very very human and the
vulnerable brilliantly no idea he was
still in business
I think well no you're not acting as a
person would act or even as a hobbit
would act or as an elf you know I think
still if it's about you try it is about
you trying to look heroic or if it's
about you trying to look cool or sexy
well it's not it's not interested I'm
not interested you know it because then
you've forgotten the point of the scene
you know if you're trying to get your
cheekbones into it you know so fortunate
for me I don't have any cheekbones so
that's not a bit sort of worry for me
ever there are parts of him facially and
physically that I felt I was thinking of
like a sort of woodland creature
gentleman like not even a specific one
I'm not even that detailed an actor just
like just a woodland creature which one
don't know but just something a creature
whose ears go what's that you mean like
someone who's gonna be hunted because
obviously hobbits are not carnivores
they're not like the top of the food
chain they're just peaceful getting on
with it farmers
you know live on the land rural people
you just like a land food you know and
living a quiet life so I thought all
that okay he's not an alligator
you know I mean like he's he's just
someone who just wants to gather berries
and obviously creatures who gather
berries have got things hunting them and
so I think he was just his radar was
always up also the feet you know if
you've got feet this big it makes you
walk in a different way because you're
picking up your legs more than you would
normally have to do to get clearance
from the ground for the toes you know so
that gives you a different gait yeah I
just had to sort of again walk that line
of giving them all the humanity you can
because he's basically carrying you
through three films but also remembering
that he's not just he's not actually
just a dude he's not he's a they're not
human I mean that they're human ish but
they're not exactly the same as us sure
my only preconception was potentially
negative and turned out to be wrong
thankfully you know but my feeling was
that we need an updated Sherlock you
know yeah I kind of felt at its worst it
would be wilfully sort of anachronistic
and cool and hey we're making him drive
you know like a sports cut you know just
stuff that was that I would find
annoying actually you know but I wasn't
reckoning all of course on how good
Steven Moffat and Mark Gatiss were and I
should have known because I know they're
very good but I only thought that for
five minutes and then I thought and I
saw their script and thoughtless within
page three I think yes is really really
smart it's exciting it's funny it's
visceral and you knew that if it was
going to be shot and directed well it
this was going to be a great show
that was revealed the most ridiculous
thing I've ever done
can you invaded Afghanistan Benedict I
think was already on board and I came
back for my call back and read with him
and it became clear immediately that we
had a rhythm together that was unusual
as in unusually easy and we complemented
each other very very well I had no
interest in being and nor was it written
like that a bumbling kind of slightly
foolish fall guy do you mean I thought
well the world doesn't need to see that
I don't want to can play that and it
wasn't that anyway so it it allowed me
to sort of be to be a strong character
as well you know and to cut him down a
bit and to take the piss out of him so
it was a bit more equal than others
Sherlock and on as John Watson over
there somewhere you know I mean clearly
it's still Sherlock it's still more
Sherlock show than John's obviously but
still it was much more even-handed and
then I think a lot of the versions of
that of that friendship that we've ever
seen you know
Alex Woodbridge didn't know anything
special about us and that it no chance
he was an amateur astronomer of that cab
it was a sort of barbed friendship and a
sort of angular friendship it wasn't
kind of just the easy hey it was you
know we kind of took lumps out of each
other sometimes no and I loved that but
yeah it was it was one of those things
of chemistry you can't manufacture and
you can't fake it was it was very
fortunate because as soon as we started
reading together I thought oh this would
really really work and I already knew
him a little bit his work I thought he
was really really good and I thought
yeah he's gonna be great I would love to
do this cuz I think this could be a very
good show love actually only vaguely a
bugbear when people girl you played that
porn star in Love Actually
well okay it wasn't actually meant to be
a porn star was meant to be to people
who were standing on a film set but fine
you know that's the sort of most often
misunderstood one of my roles I think I
was working with Joanna page in our
scenes and she you know she had to have
her top off fairly quickly and by the
way he introduced me as John but
actually everyone Jack nice to meet you
jack Richard Curtis makes a very good
set you know he sets the tone he tries
to put everyone at ease as humanly
possible whatever they're doing I was
fully dressed she was half dressed I had
to be behind her gently sort of cupping
her breasts right you know about a
minute after we've met so but the comedy
being that we're having mundane everyday
conversations while we're in this
ridiculous position or while I'm in a
position of pretend to be hit thrusting
her while we're talking about how bad
the traffic was getting here kind of
again to sweet people having a sweet
conversation but as stand-ins on a movie
set sort of acting out very sexual stuff
you know being naked or nearly naked is
always kind of it's a tough one and it's
you know it's not because that in front
of however many people it's not the
first thing you would volunteer for I
don't think man or woman it's not the
first thing you think I know I've got an
idea and so in that sense you need to
hopefully be enjoying it and you need to
really focus on it on a well rate
the scene it's very different if you're
doing a love scene or a sex scene which
these were not because that is about you
know love and sex and all baby this was
about something totally that you know
the dialogue could have been should have
been happening in a cafe with two people
just having a chat over a cup of coffee
you know but it was happening when we
were both naked and I was pretending to
you know it's lovely to find someone
that can actually chat to like it's very
incongruous hence the comedy
I hope black panther well yeah that
what's nice about playing over at Ross
in black panther is and before that in
civil war once he gets to makanda he's
absolutely a fish out of water so I
suppose in some way the way that he was
viewing this technology and like this
futuristic place is a sort of audience
conduit as well because we don't live in
Wakanda and we don't live in that sort
of futuristic world he is a very very
high status in his world in his job very
high status person and then to have that
all taken away and he saw it has no
status that was interesting I guess I've
often played people who find themselves
in extraordinary circumstances what you
were a great pilot
don't worry I'll guide you through it
it's just like riding a hammer Black
Panther was one of those that obviously
you get on the Marvel train and the
train is operating just fine without you
it's going to carry on with or without
you just fine and it's one of the few
things that you will ever do in your
life where you know there is a huge
audience for it most other things you do
in your life you hope there's going to
be an audience for it but this is a big
old train as it has been rolling just
fine
so that will people will see it people
definitely watch this but the extent of
which was again very overwhelming and
very gratifying
you know people loved it
the last cargo ship is almost at the
border when they got me trapped with
some kind of cable muscle joke
impression of Ryan was that he would
walk away and come back four times
show me nice a is a there a lot of
stroking of his beard it was a mighty
beard as well the more it went on he got
like he was a good old beard and a lot
of stroking of that lots of pauses yeah
and then go away figure and then he
comes back it's like Columbo one more
thing I mean that is not not to give the
impression he was in any way
uber controlling around he's totally
trusting I felt I had a lot of freedom
on that set you know like I felt like
people were playing if they wanted to
play you could definitely play it wasn't
keeping you in a box because he trusted
his actors but he just if he had a
detailed thing that he wanted you to
think about he really wanted you to get
every syllable of what he meant I think
he hates the idea of being misunderstood
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy I think
one of my skills in life I think is
being quite good at not feeling amazing
pressure
I genuinely don't I don't really feel
pressure that much at work I feel
pressure in other ways in family life
and like real life I can feel pressure
at the drop of a hat but in work it
takes a lot for me to really feel
intimidated you know man I couldn't feel
that playing Bilbo didn't feel that
playing John what I don't because I
think well I've got every right to have
a go of this you know someone else will
have a go in 20 years and someone else
had to go before and they're perfectly
entitled to it this is my go you know
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy had
been a radio show it had been albums
they've been a TV show in the in the UK
in the early 80s that I remember as a
young kid and the portrayal of Arthur
and I'll it and it was it's a good
portrayal of Arthur it's kind of how
it's written as a sort of archetypal
middle-class slightly posh man who was
bamboozled by everything I thought
there's something in me obviously
they've seen they want me to do it and
this is what a long time ago I said all
they would have seen really was the
office do you know I mean I thought well
I've just got to be the truth that I can
bring to it as opposed to somebody else
his name is Arthur Dent he is a 5-foot
eighteenth tall ape descendant and
someone is trying to drive a bypass
through his house when you're playing a
completely different version like a
cover version of the same song you've
got to just do your own version I think
I was very aware that a lot of people I
love and people in my family were dying
I was so pleased that I was doing it and
so I wanted to honor that and I was
really pleased for them and I was
pleased for the people who I loved who
loved the books but yes I think I'm
quite good at not feeling overruled by
things to be honest I try and treat
things quite soberly and even though of
course I get excited about of course I
do
and I am on my knees and metaphorically
every day thanking God that I'm an actor
before you start having your own party
about how excited you can do the work
and the works hard it's hard to be good
you know so I really really want to be
good in this job so I want to sort of
concentrate on it so I and you just know
that feeling that pressure is not going
to help it's not going to help at all
I think I'm a big believer and everyone
does their best work when they're a
little bit relaxed or when they feel
free you know if you contain someone and
sort of try and control what they're
doing and scare them people are doing
people work well out of fear but I think
acting is really fun it's really fun and
and it should and it should be and I'm
only ever gonna be half decent at it if
I'm enjoying it so no I didn't feel
pressure Fargo I along with the rest of
the world when when we started to in
Fargo who just watched Breaking Bad
right and so that there was a there was
a hint of that there was a hint of that
in it straight person trying to do his
best
I mean less there was far more beta he's
described in the scriptures a sort of
person who if you knocked into him he
would apologize to you but he has his
own little journey of a turn something
happens in his life and it's not the
same again it was tied you know I I was
someone standing up to that I was I was
being a man
and then of course much later on we join
him and he's you say he's he's become a
kind of alpha and just when he thinks
his life is gonna be alpha then then
something happens again and it's all
gone because I suppose in real life I
believe in chaos and I believe in I
believe that a lot of things are chaos
and it's I suppose I believe in that
more than I believe in conspiracy
generally I believe in the [ __ ] up you
know and one second split-second
decision changes his life completely
obviously you know he didn't plan it him
want it to happen a Sarah he wasn't
thinking how can I kill my one as well
as an actor I like dealing with the UM I
like I like a character dealing with the
unknown and I like a character it's more
interesting I guess I mean even though
I'd love to play the guy who comes off a
yacht with a margarita I'd love I'd love
to I can do that but but I suppose
really what I find interesting is the
stuff that I find interesting in real
life which is how do we yeah we all
coping German how we all work in this
out Lester had that in spades I mean he
was just constantly like a very very
reactive character reacting to bigger
and more cynical people than himself
what do you mean
forensic I stay in the accent all all
day from the time I'm picked up in the
morning to rap I have a pretty good ear
right so I'll be able to do a fairly
good stab at an accent like quite
quickly but I think after a while you
would starts are hearing consistencies
if you treat it like a sketch or a skit
you know you're not in SNL you're not
just doing a gag you've got to go over
10 hours of believing these people so
you can't mock you can't take a short
cut and go they probably sound something
like this you know so I wanted to really
do it properly I obviously had help a
couple of sessions before we started
shooting there was a guy on set all the
time while we were shooting if I would
ever have like a week away from work
what I mean I would use YouTube there
were a couple of videos that I used of
young guys from Minnesota
just took just talking once you've got
that keyed into your DNA for the time
being you just need to quickly refresh
it if you haven't if you've not been
talking like that for a while I would
just like to say how sorry I am about
your husband he so some people of course
say we don't sound like that and other
people from Minnesota say no we do yeah
you got it and I think I I was very
happy in that a lot of people from
Minnesota said I mean no that was that
was pretty good so I'll take that all
day long
yeah the world's end I've known Edgar
and Simon for a long time it felt a
little bit like like a gang of mates
getting together and so having fun
because I know them it was as I hoped
and expected it would be really you know
it's just fun but but work cuz that the
it's still obviously a it's graph
you know because you are still coming in
very early going home late and the
cliche is especially in comedy you've
got to work hard like yeah I think you
gotta work hard all in time you know but
but it especially if you're trying to
make things funny it's not it's not
always massively easy just sometimes
sometimes it's but not always
yeah Gary WTF it's good to see you too
oh man please don't call me oh man
sure Oliver Chamberlain was written as
everyone's annoying yuppie idiot you
know like the way the characters are
introduced you have to get a pretty easy
read on all of them I guess and his is a
sort of work obsessed career-obsessed
yappy who's it had been a yuppie from
the age of like 16 I think that's where
he saw himself you know it makes yeah it
makes bold films Edgar because when you
think it's always it's this sort of film
and then it's actually it's also sort of
there's martial arts bits there's great
great fights in it fantastic fight
sequences in it and then of course the
whole sci-fi dystopian bit but he's got
a he's got a real ambition and energy to
his work I think and sometimes you see
him over at the monitor acting out with
his every sinew of his body everything
we're doing and very occasionally with
the director and I've had it before I've
had it many times before where you do
something new catch the director kind of
going
oh that you know I guess they didn't
laugh when you see the disappointment on
a director's face that something you've
just done you you know
but he's a he's a real dynamo breeders
breed has started with me it started as
my idea and I sort of then brought it to
my clever con phrase Chris Addison and
Simon Blackwell and we developed this
show together and it came out of for me
and I think similarly for Simon and
Chris as we found out in our various
father's meetings after that which we
pretended were development meetings
barrace was like the father's therapy
sort of thing
yeah it's the discovery that at the
center of it Paul who I play is a person
who has thought all his life he's a nice
guy he's been told he's a nice person
I'm I'm a nice guy and with this guy and
then you become a father and then you
realize there is a side to you that is
not that like impatient spoiled entitled
and having someone read your fortune
like that and they're a baby is like
that's quite alarming you know in my own
experience lots of things came out about
my personality like it's kind of amazing
it's amazing because at the same time as
you're feeling more love for a person
than you felt possible to feel and I
still feel obviously about my two kids
it's possible to turn on a dime and want
to throw yourself out of a window
[Music]
breeders we've hopefully managed to get
a world where it's as many things in the
program as it is in real life is you
know in the course of an hour I will be
kissing them laughing with them hugging
them shouting at them trying to feed
them you know like it's all of it and
it's all encompassing one of the things
that made me want to do it was I
couldn't go to any more nice London
dinner parties where people were just
going isn't it amazing being a parent
isn't it isn't it just incredible but
yeah of course it is like like for me
the love thing takes
itself there's no question you're gonna
adore this child
I even this isn't helping akiza my job
is the same everywhere if I make a
student film next week then my job is
the same as it is on Black Panther is to
convince in in that scene you know it's
to be truthful to that scene and you
know I say this but I think it's true
the difference is catering you know
that's craft service is the biggest
difference it's all the same really
apart for apart from all the whistles
and bells your job is exactly the same
everything in life everything in life is
easy everything unless you want to be
good at it if you're doing well it's
really Kenard football piece of cake be
good at it it's a bit harder you know I
mean acting I think I'm always thinking
oh yeah I'm trying to always play it off
it's not down a - it's pretty good to be
good at it it's not that easy actually
you know it's all the lifetime struggle
to try and be a good actor and it that
and that work never stops I've done so
many iconic roles got ups I'm such an
amazing icon yeah why is no one doing
that